welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul bit of a different video
for you guys today
um I don't know if you've been keeping
up with whole breakdown community on
Twitter but you might have seen recently
that Mt unfortunately got laid off at
his job um he's been looking for work
and you know I immediately hit him up
and was like do you do you want to do
something as part of the heavy spoilers
show now I know for a while MTS wanted
to do a big breakdown on Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 and I thought this is
the perfect opportunity for us to just
come together make it work and yeah for
this video Mt is going to be going
through the whole movie scene by scene
and pointing out all the Easter eggs in
it so yeah really excited to work with
another creator that I've watched for
years and years and years I really
admire what the guy does you know he
he's helped me get better just by
watching him and I think he's so
talented when it comes to this breakdown
stuff as I'm sure you can tell we're
very excited to get into it and here's
heavy spoilers Presents mt's breakdown
of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. what's
Poppin jubes Welcome to the heavy
spoiler show my name is Mt from
youtube.com Smash retainment and this is
a breakdown of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. I am beyond excited to talk about
the conclusion to the greatest Trilogy
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in my
opinion and I want to thank the
spectacular spoiler man himself Paul
spoilers for giving me the opportunity
to be a complete weirdo in front of all
of you today on this spectacular channel
so let's get into it right at the very
beginning before the Marvel Studios logo
starts flashing all the best MCU moments
of the Guardians of the Galaxy we can
see the word Showtime a-holes in script
text a direct reference to Star-Lord
getting ready to fight the
interdimensional obelisk in Guardians 2
as well as Marvel's incredibly cheeky
way of declaring showtime for the film
and this is Then followed by Peter's
Guardians 2 line about there being an
unspoken thing drax's Guardians 2 line
about there being two types of people in
the universe those who dance and those
who do not dance adult groups we are
Groot from guardians 1 and both of
rockets Guardians 1 lines of jackass is
standing in a circle and ain't nothing
like me except me the latter being
foreshadowing for the end of the movie
when rocket discovers he was wrong the
entire time after he finds a cage of
baby raccoons because it turns out the
high evolutionary stole a bunch of
animals from North America on Terra a
long time ago including a bunch of baby
raccoons from the Columbus Wildlife
Center though the first two letters in
Columbus appear to have disappeared over
time so it kind of looks like Columbus
Wildlife Center but what I truly love
about this part with all these baby
raccoons embracing rocket when he opens
their cage is that this moment is a
direct contrast to how the movie
actually opens up with the flashback to
Rocket's own early days as a baby
raccoon being deathly afraid of the
coming approach of his abusive apathetic
God the high evolutionary whose
predatory hand Towers over a fearful
baby rocket like a claw and a claw
machine or an animalistic predator in
the sky every single Guardians of the
Galaxy movie has opened up with an
important flashback for that movie's
main captain of the Guardians we got
flashbacks of Meredith Quill's death and
Peter Quill's abduction in Guardians 1
followed by a flashback of Peter's
parents in Guardians 2. now with rocket
ending this rocket-centric movie as the
captain of the Guardians starting with a
Rocket Raccoon flashback this time
around was very appropriate then after
we see rocket rapidly age up into the
rocket of the modern day we can hear him
listening to an acoustic version of
Creep by Radiohead but what I truly love
about this moment is that it appears
that rocket only sings the parts of the
song that he can personally relate to
like when he sings when you were here
before couldn't look you in the eye
you're just like an angel your skin
makes me cry that makes me feel like
rocket is singing about Lila and his old
disfigured friends who are now just like
angels in the sky then rocket sings I'm
a weirdo and I want to have control I
want a perfect body obviously pointing
to how he feels about his own self his
tragic past and how he feels like he has
no control over his life and his death
Destiny it's really super sad stuff but
it's also an incredibly clever use of
this acoustic cover by James Gunn but
anyways as Rocket walks around nowhere
we can see that nowhere has continued to
grow as the guardian city-sized Haven
for any lost alien Soul who needs a home
in the Galaxy especially since we last
saw it in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special a special where we
learned that the Guardians purchased the
entirety of this empty Celestial Noggin
from The Collector himself though I
imagine that after nowhere was destroyed
by Thanos seven or eight years prior he
was more than eager to be rid of that
place and the Guardians forever because
every time the Guardians show up
something bad happens to him but man it
is really hard to believe that it has
been nearly 12 MCU years since we first
met the Guardians in 2014 but hey the
progress definitely shows their family
has grown exponentially because that
city is freaking huge but anyways rocket
walks past a Drax who claims that only
idiots dance to a dancing mantis this is
not only a reference to his quote to
Peter about those who dance and those
who do not dance but it's also a tease
for the changed person that Drax will
become by the end of the film when he
uses his idiotic dancing to bring joy to
all of the Star children then when
rocket observes Groot and nebula hang up
a new Guardians of the Galaxy neon sign
written in the galactic language of the
Andromeda galaxy the man the myth the
legend Stephen Blackheart can be seen
standing right behind them returning to
his role as steamy blue liver because
remember that dispatcher dude on nowhere
that Drax threatened with a knife to
contact Ronan in Guardians 1. he's back
this time he's got a gun Stephen
Blackheart is actually a close personal
actor friend of James Gunn and those two
homies have worked together on a bunch
of projects like PG porn super the
Bellco experiment brightburn and even
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 when he played
one of the alien ravagers more recently
Steven has played the pilots Briscoe in
The Suicide Squad and the Savage Charlie
the gorilla and Peacemaker the greatest
TV show of all time I'm sorry I don't
make the rules that TV show is just
awesome but anyway Steven Blackheart is
a fantastic man and he and I have been
social media homies for years now as he
has been a huge help on my hunt for the
big missing Guardians of the Galaxy 1
Easter egg so give Stephen Blackheart a
follow at Blackheart on Instagram right
now that is a demand he's a great man go
like his pictures but anyways rocket
then enters a common eating area to a
drunk Star-Lord wearing a shirt with an
orloni on it that says space candy
Star-Lord has apparently been getting
blackout drunk extremely regularly as
his not so great way of getting over his
loss of Gamora the fridge that rocket
approaches is apparently a massive
fridge filled with milky Fizz as that is
the words written on the glass and don't
worry it's not like carbonated milk or
anything that sounds disgusting and I
would throw up right now carbonated milk
would have definitely killed rocket
before Adam Warlock even got there this
Milky fizz drink is apparently supposed
to taste like desert pear soda water
with cream and it's something that
people have actually tasted in real life
at the Pim Test Kitchen at Avengers
campus in California but anyways I
really dig the chandelier speakers on
the ceiling in this eating area because
it really shows just how much Peter
Quill's love of music has been built
into all of nowhere like there are
speakers everywhere so everyone can
dance at the end of the movie I really
like how James Gunn sort of symbolically
filled nowhere Celestial head with music
much like Meredith build ego's head with
music when he was on Earth it's kind of
like history repeating itself in a
symbolic way but anyways as a
disappointed nebula carries a passed out
Peter we get one of the last James Gunn
slow walks of the MCU badass slow motion
Hero Walks is one of James Gunn favorite
things in this world and he's done it in
every Guardians movie as well as his
newer DC projects like The Suicide Squad
and Peacemaker and also fun fact about
Chris Pratt in this shot he's not
actually in this shot that's just a
disturbingly lifelike Chris Pratt dummy
that they made so Karen Gillen could
bench the weight of a collapsed Star
Lord but if you just assume that Karen
Gillen was just swole like that I
wouldn't blame you Karen gillen's got
the guns but anyways as nebula puts
Peter to bed Peter Whispers I love you
Gamora while grabbing nebula's arm
before Radiohead sings the words I wish
I was special very much implying to me
that nebula might just be developing
some slight romantic feelings towards
Peter as she has been trying to take
care of him for her dead sister Gamora
throughout this entire movie nebula is
extremely protective of Star-Lord while
also bickering with him like a married
couple so I wouldn't be surprised if
they ended up as the father and mother
figures to all the citizens of nowhere
down the line I mean Karen Gillen did
recently tease nebula's tiny crush on on
Star-Lord in an interview so but
definitely it feels likely that this was
intentional by James Gunn and Rocket
even asked nebula what she is going to
do about Peter's drunk ass because the
rocket is too busy dealing with his own
emotionalistical issues and nebula seems
to be the most concerned for Peter out
of all of the whole Guardians family but
also rocket even acknowledging that he
has emotional issues in the first place
is definitely a shout out to Rocket's
growth in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
when he learns that he doesn't have to
be a jerk that pushes people away
despite his trauma but anyways while
those two talk we of course get a sneak
preview of the handy dandy gravity boots
that rocket will end up using to escape
the high evolutionaries clutches at the
end of the film but then we are finally
introduced to the true star of the movie
Cosmo the space dog as played by actress
Maria bakalova during a car game with
her former collector jail mates Howard
the Duck we learn in this movie that
Cosmo is a little over 60 freaking years
old and she was sent away on a rocket on
a suicide science Mission from Russia in
1966 in the 60s are coincidentally the
era that doctor strange hints that the
Fantastic Four were popular in in
Multiverse of Madness so I wouldn't be
surprised if the Soviets were interested
in that same weird cosmic energy
readings in space that the Fantastic
Four were in their origin story but
instead of sending humans into space
like America did with the Fantastic Four
the Russian sent Cosmo into space to go
check out those readings and then Cosmo
got superpowers but anyways after Cosmo
shows cragling up with her cool
telekinesis Powers by hitting targets
engraved with the love bugs of contraxia
from Guardians 2 we learned that there
was a distinct difference between how
Cosmo and craglin use their similar
looking Powers when craglin declares
Cosmo a bad dog because telekinesis is
cheating while Cosmos powers are
telekinetic in nature kraglan's use of
yandu's Fin and arrow are not rooted in
the mind but the emotions of the heart
which is why the yondu of Christmas Past
shows off briefly towards the end of the
film to remind kraglan how to fly the
arrow he has to use his heart it's sort
of like a patho kinetic telekinesis in a
way it's very reliant on emotions but
anyways as the Guardians try to figure
out what to do with Peter's depression
while eating some fried orlony Rockets
suggests that mantis use her powers to
touch him to make him happy but Groot of
course takes it in the sexual way
because Groot is a teenager who is
raised by the inappropriate Star-Lord
and while this is a hilarious joke this
could also be a slight nod to mantis's
short time as a prostitute in the comics
meant to Showcase just how different
this MCU version of mantis is to these
very outdated Comics but anyways as
raqqa gets prepared to go to sleep for a
lot longer than he intended we can see
the same high evolutionary surgery scars
on Rockets back that we got a glimpse of
when we first went to the Kiln prison in
Guardians 1. these back scars are a big
reason why director James Gunn wanted to
return to Marvel to finish the Guardians
Trilogy because he always intended to
tell Rocket's tragic backstory from the
very beginning because Rocket Raccoon
has always been James Gunn's Secret main
protagonist of the trilogy which is
something that Lila's Spirit hints at to
Rocket later on in the film when she
says the line the story has always been
yours you just didn't know it then as
Crazy On You by heart plays we finally
get the debut of Adam Warlock to the MCU
after the Guardians 2 post-credits scene
had Aisha first begin his birthing
process 11 to 12 years prior to the
events of Guardians 3. reporting his
comic accurate red and yellow colors and
skull on the chest Adam Warlock glows
with a golden fire very similar to
Captain Marvel's however it looks like
James Gunn decided to use a raccoon
skull this time around which I thought
was a nice touch given Aisha in the
sovereign's disdain for Rockets theft of
their batteries and Guardians 2. and
though Adam does appear to have a stone
on his forehead like he does in the
comics this Stone's purpose has yet to
be revealed in the MCU so we don't
really know why that's there but if I
were to guess I would assume that there
was a probably a tube or something
attached to his forehead that was
basically acting like an umbilical cord
feeding him all of the energy into his
body that he needed to become the
ultimate highly evolved Sovereign
creature and it also appears that Adam
Warlock new rocket raccoon's exact
location before he even left the
Sovereign planet to go get him likely
using the high evolutionaries kill
switch locked around Rocket's internal
organs to find him and then as Adam
faces off with nebula we can see
nebula's new and improved nanotech arm
in action an arm that she reveals later
on was made for her by Rocket Raccoon
himself likely as a thank you for her
gifting him Bucky's vibranium arm and
the holiday special like this arm
definitely feels like rocket was
inspired heavily by Tony Stark and the
wakanda nanotechnology during his time
on Earth with the Avengers and I
honestly wouldn't be surprised if rocket
repurposed Bucky's arm to make this new
arm for nebula but anyways the very
flexible nanotech nature of nebula's arm
allows nebula to transform it into a
mega man-like arm Cannon a sword like
razor Fist from Shang Chi an electro
shock Cannon a laser cutter and even a
weird suction arm like Lila said it's
always good to have friends especially
friends who can make your arm turn into
a weapon but anyways at the end of Adam
and group's anime style fight through
the air Adam destroys all of groot's
body except for groot's head which he
mercifully drops to the ground instead
of destroying it both pointing to Adam's
very kind nature underneath his douchey
personality and confirming that the only
thing that the Groot species needs to
survive are their heads and then when
nebula uses her superheated sword arm to
stab Adam through the chest will
poulter's excellent delivery of that
hurts was perfect because that was very
likely the first time this Godlike being
had ever experienced true pain but
nebula could not give a singular Dan
because all she knows in her life is
pain as she was the daughter of the very
abusive Thanos but anyways as Rocket
lies on the floor unconscious we get a
series of flashbacks to Rocket raccoon's
creation at orete laboratories on
counter Earth or half world and in these
flashbacks we can see the letters 89p13
being tattooed onto rocket skin with the
prefix 8 9 referring to the high
evolutionaries batch 89 which of course
are Rockets soon to be slain friends
floor who is 8906 teefs The Walrus who
is 89895 and Lila who was 89q12 batch 89
appears to be heavily inspired by the
Rocket Raccoon Comics as the comic book
rocker raccoon goes on adventures with
Lila walrus and a rabbit named Blackjack
O'Hare rocket raccoon's bestie while
Ross was even teased in a lovebot motel
on contraxia in Guardians 2. James Gunn
literally had an artist recreate the
second panel on page 3 of 1985's Rocket
Raccoon number two possibly as a tease
for thiefs in Guardians 3 and when the
four caged friends all named themselves
later on in the film we finally learned
why rocket calls himself rocket it's
after the dream he's always had of
building a rocket to fly into the blue
sky with all of his friends forever
which definitely makes the Guardians 2
moment of Rocket saying that he was
cybernetically engineered to Pilot a
spacecraft hit a lot different in
retrospect also the inclusion of Mr Blue
Sky by the Electric Light Orchestra
playing at the start of Guardians 2 as
well but anyway speaking of The Rocker
raccoon Comics the Guardians then head
to orgo corpse orgoscope after nebula
connects to Rocket's vital data and
learns of the existence of the high
evolutionaries kill switch passkey the
outer design of the orgoscope feels
heavily inspired by the space wheel from
the early Rocket Raccoon comics in the
comics space wheel was the headquarters
of Rocket raccoon's maid adversary Lord
Divine who ran a company called
divinities Incorporated a company that
made toys and killer clown robots but in
the MCU orgo corpse orgoscope is the
bioformed science headquarters of Rocket
raccoons made adversary the high
evolutionary with bioformed meaning that
the high evolutionary grew the entire
station out of living organic matter
which is why the whole station has a
bunch of eyeballs and whatnot organic
matter that I highly suspect to have
come from the collector's farming of
nowhere's biology for hundreds of years
I mean both The Collector and the high
evolutionary are both super long-lived
people after all so I can definitely see
them being in business for a very long
time but instead of making toys like
space wheel did in the comics orgocorp
has been providing cybernetic implants
and genetic upgrades for anyone who will
buy them for over 300 years mostly so
the high evolutionary can use all that
money to fund all of his super messed up
experiments throughout the Universe and
orgocorp is also known for having the
most advanced cybernetic IP in the
Galaxy including all the patents to
every species the high evolutionary has
ever created himself including the anime
the zeronians The Sovereign the
hellspawn the recorders the humanimals
of counter Earth and of course all the
failed experiments in between like
subject 89p13 of batch 89 I kind of feel
like orgo Corp species patent room has a
lot of similarities to the celestial
World Forge from eternals because like
the celestial God erishim stores all the
memories of his experiments in a massive
library of neurons the high evolutionary
sort of does the same thing by storing
crucial memories within the neurons of
these tiny pink brain balls that cyborgs
like nebula or the high availability
missionaries or quarters can access with
their computer brains anyways in order
to even get inside of orgo Corp Peter
and nebula have to work together to
bypass or grow corpse invisible
three-layered shielding another element
seemingly inspired by the early rocker
raccoon Comics as comic Rocket's home of
half world had a giant galatian wall
surrounding the Keystone quadrant that
one needed to bypass to even get to the
planet but when the Guardians finally
get past those oral Corp Shields they
run into the United ravagers yondu
udanta's old crew of ravagers who all
put aside their differences and reunited
after yondu's funeral though in
Guardians 3 it seems that only Sylvester
Stallone's Dakar Michael rosenbaum's
Martin X Krueger and Mainframe are still
together after all these years with the
voice actor for Miss minutes Tara Strong
pulling double MCU Duty as Mainframe to
fill in for Miley Cyrus this time around
Vin Rhames as charlie27 and Michelle
Yo's eileta ogord are noticeably absent
but picking up their slack is of course
the new was member of the United
ravagers Gamora 2 Multiverse Boogaloo
the gamor from the alternate 2014 that
Thanos emerged from in Avengers end game
this Gamora is noticeably different from
the Gamora that we've known from the
past two Guardians films because she
lacked the valuable lessons in love and
family that the original Gamora learned
in those movies this Gamora is purely
the recently freed daughter of Thanos
who is living up to her reputation as
the most dangerous woman in the Galaxy
it is because of these lack of
experiences that Kimura eventually snaps
at Peter for trying to make her the
lover that she never was by delivering
one of the most important lines in the
Guardians Trilogy in my opinion what are
you so afraid of in yourself that I need
to be something for you this line is
super important because it touches on an
important theme in Guardians 3
confronting one's fears both rocket and
Star-Lord started the Guardians Trilogy
running from their past parental traumas
but Star-Lord in particular had been
using Gamora to fill the Meredith quill
sized hole in his heart instead of
taking his ass back to Missouri and
seeing the grandfather that he left
behind this new variant Gamora saw that
desperation within Peter and called him
out on it almost immediately after he
kept pestering her about not being the
dead Gomorrah and good for her quite
honestly because Peter really needed to
hear that much like he needed to hear
mantisen drax's metaphor on how life is
a pond and how Peter tends to hop from
Woman to Woman Like lily pads instead of
learning how to swim which is extremely
reflective of the sea metaphor that ego
uses in Guardians 2 with Meredith quill
when he refers to Meredith as his River
Lily in the sea of his expansion and
while ego and Peter were very of
different people at the end of the day
the one flaw that they have in common
was spending their entire lives
attaching to the love of random women
for their own selfish reasons the Apple
doesn't fall too far from the tree later
on in the movie while Gamora is
listening to Alice Cooper's I'm always
Chasing Rainbows trying to figure out
exactly why Peter is always pathetically
chasing her she does the totally cool
thing and looks through Peter's old
backpack that he's had when he was
kidnapped by yondu at eight years old a
backpack with a NASA and Earth patch to
Showcase Peter's love for astronomy of
monkey shark and palm tree patch to show
Peter's love of Nature and five Pac-Man
ghosts to show Peter's love of arcade
games like Pac-Man I mean Peter loves
Pac-Man so much that he literally turned
into Pac-Man while fighting ego in
Guardians 2. though it is odd that Peter
would have five Pac-Man ghosts instead
of the classic four considering that
kinky the yellow Pac-Man ghost wasn't
introduced until 1996 Pac-Man
arrangement and Peter left Earth in
1988. however since Pac-Man is always
chasing these rainbow ghosts they all
definitely fit in with the theme of the
song that is playing in this moment also
I don't know why they decided to name
the yellow ghost kinky like
why would you do that
like really was there no board meeting
about that but anyways inside of Peter's
backpack Gamora pulls out some ALF and
Garbage Pail Kids training cards the
Garfield books Garfield eats his heart
out and Garfield Takes the Cake as well
as a he-man toy Star Lord's love for
He-Man shows extra hard later on in the
film when he calls the high evolutionary
a stretched face RoboCop looking
Skeletor wannabe purple nurple piece of
[__] much like I call anyone who cuts me
off in Boston traffic but most notably
we can see Peter's old report card from
Saint Charles Elementary in Missouri we
can see that Peter was getting seized in
reading and social studies D's in
science and math but a solid B and PE
with PE being the only class that he
gets a favorable comment from a teacher
with a rest complaining of Peter's
laziness and math disruptive nature
during reading inappropriate comments
during science and talkative nature
during social studies this is all very
much in line with star-lord's
personality now as he very much excels
at physical Feats more than anything
else but anyways when stock car pulls up
with the United ravagers I love how the
light from his suit makes it look like
he has wings because those light Wings
Plus his blue and gold helmet definitely
helps the car feel a lot like the Star
Hawk from the Marvel Comics but anyways
after the Guardians grab their disguises
from stacar and begin their oral Corp
infiltration they run into a number of
James Gunn's favorite actors to work
with including Nathan Fillion as orgo
Sentry Captain karja who is actually
returning to the Guardians Trilogy after
playing a monstrous inmate in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 1. Jennifer Holland as
the orgo scope administrator quo and
Daniela melchior who plays the krylorian
the Peter fortsworth named Ura all three
of these actors have roles in James
Gunn's DC Universe as the detachable kid
Harcourt and rat catcher 2 respectively
though Nathan Fillion has recently been
announced as Guy Gardner and James
Gunn's new DCU and honestly that is
probably the most baller casting I've
heard in a long-ass time like not even
gonna lie Nathan Fillion was born for
that role that is like RDJ levels of
perfect casting but moving on as Gamora
starts telling the Guardians what to do
as they move throughout the orgoscope
Gamora calls mantis bug which is of
course a comment on mantis's antennas
but also a clever nod to one of the
original members of star-lord's
Guardians of the Galaxy team in the
comics bug who Marvel Studios could not
use at all in their Universe due to bug
being owned by Hasbro as part of the
micronauts property but anyways as the
Guardians continue to move through
orbital Corp and eventually Escape by
lifting all the Oracle sentries off the
ground much like rocket did with the
Kiln prison guards and Guardians 1. we
get another flashback of rocket and the
high evolutionary as they listen to The
High evolutionary's favorite 5 000 year
old song MOA ograss de funones featuring
I spice if I just accidentally summoned
a demon into your bedroom I formally
apologize Latin is not my first language
a title that translates to be not as you
are but as you should be which perfectly
encapsulates the high evolutionaries
main mission of turning all the
imperfect elements in the universe into
one perfect Symphony of Science which is
why he refers to Rocket as a medley of
mistakes later on in the film to the
high evolutionary he's not just making
monsters he's making music and music is
a big theme throughout the entire
Guardians Trilogy so having an evil
music man is very fitting but when the
high evolutionary brings rocker raccoon
to assess the aggression problem inside
of his enraged mutant danger turtles
that he made rocket points out that the
problem was an overproduction of
something called the Liga Beto micro
cemento protein which is a real protein
closely linked to aggression in animals
like squids as noted in a study
conducted in 2011. this is is when the
high evolutionary completely loses his
[__] [__] completely at the mere
thought of one of his lowly experiments
crafting an ingenious thought that he
could not come up with himself I really
love how chukwudi awuji crawls on the
ground like a predatory animal as he
approaches Rocket's cage and again later
on as he slowly approaches rocket to
berate him him crawling on the ground
like an animal while rocket stood
upright was an excellent piece of
imagery to show which one of them was
truly the most evolved on the inside but
anyways after the Guardians learned that
recorder Thiel one of the high
evolutionary's most sadistic cyborgs
responsible for Rocket's torturous past
who Peter bumped into during the oral
Corp infiltration downloaded and deleted
the passkey before the Guardians got to
it first the Guardians resolved to head
to counter Earth despite Gamora
selfishly warning them not to and much
like Drax did with Ronan in the first
film Gamora ends up making a selfish
phone call that ends up alerting Aisha
and Adam to the guardian's location and
as the Guardians fight over the surface
of counter Earth Peter discovers that it
is a near perfect Recreation of planet
Earth Circa the 1980s the same era that
Peter left his planet Earth and
according to the film and director James
Gunn on Twitter the high evolutionary
visited counter Earth one time in the
1980s and was so impressed with Earth's
culture that he decided to base the
entirety of counter Earth on his loose
memories of that visit which is why we
can see a version of The Statue
of remade to include the high
evolutionary and a monkey and why all
the people architecture cars and Home
Decor all look super retro I really hope
it was a night monkey no way home
scenario that happened at that Statue of
Liberty because that would have been
hilarious but since we do know that the
high evolutionary did visit the Earth in
the 1980s I am curious about whether or
not he teamed up with Advanced idea
mechanics or any type of Earth genius
during his visit because if you remember
in Iron Man 3 Aldridge Killian had an
entire map of the universe at his
disposal a map that he shows pepper very
briefly that map could have easily been
gifted to aim by the high evolutionary
in the 1980s before aim was even made
into a company he probably found a group
of geniuses was like hey you guys are
unethical like me here's a map to the
universe sky's the limit
but anyways as the Guardians land on
counter Earth you can see a little baby
warthog watching the ship descend while
holding a little high evolutionary
plushie blissfully unaware that they're
about to die at the hands of the very
plushie that they're holding and I
really love how James Gunn had that
rabbit man yell nanu nanu at the
Guardians after Drax absolutely
eliminates a little girl with the ball
as it is a clear reference to Robin
Williams's famous catchphrase as the
alien Mork in 1978's Mork and Mindy and
then when the people of counter Earth
start throwing rocks at the Guardians
nebula tells Groot to go full kaijumu
which is a direct reference to groot's
first ever Marvel appearance as a
massive Kaiju monster in the pages of
1960s Tales to astonish number 13 and a
tease to the massive person that group
becomes at the very end of the film then
after the Guardians make themselves a
little bit too comfortable in nearly the
vampire bathroom animals home Peter
draws Neely his beautiful rendition of
what recorder feel looks like now listen
to what Neely says in reaction to seeing
quarter Theo's face
his name his name is motio
Neely says Mojo and then shakes her head
when Peter pronounces it as mochio I
believe this is super important because
I believe this is recorder feels true
purpose in Guardians 3. I believe that
James Gunn is using recorder feel and a
bunch of elements in Guardians 3 to set
up the origin of Mojo in the MCU now
hear me out here because it's not just
some bat ladies saying a name that
points to a possible Mojo origin in
Guardians 3. the cyborg recorder feels
deeply sadistic personality towards
rocket and all of the high
evolutionaries mutated to animals and
star children appears to very much
mirror the very deep love and
fascination with torturing mutants that
the super fleshy and disgusting
spineless cyborg Mojo has in the comics
and when you consider it just how much
alike the high evolutionaries controller
pilot of the ariate Laboratories looks
oddly similar to the Mojo design in the
comics it definitely feels likely to me
that we could see recorders feel cyborg
data redownloaded and his body
reconstituted at Oracle Corp using some
of that oral Corp flesh to make his new
fleshy spineless body before adopting
the very name that all the humanimals
call him as his own Mojo but that's just
a theory a Mojo Theory but anyway
speaking of feel in the star children
phyla can be seen Defying Gravity as she
runs in front of the high evolutionary
on a high-tech hamster wheel as the high
evolutionary tells recorder feel that
his mutated star children have the
ability to survive extremely happily on
30 calories a day and an hour of sleep a
week and yet still be able to rewrite a
carbonatrix core in under two hours
without getting hangry so phyla and the
rest of her mutated friends are as super
smart as they appear to be powerful and
it's also very fitting that phyla is a
star child considering that she will
ultimately become the hero Quasar in the
MCU much like she is in the comics but
anyways when the Guardians finally
arrive at orete laboratories with orete
of course being the Greek word for
excellence in self-actualization they're
greeted by two of the most bad looking
characters in all of MCU history
Behemoth played by Ronaldo fabrell and
my personal favorite war pig as played
by actress Judy Greer who of course has
also played Maggie Lang in the Ant-Man
films like I am beyond upset that war
Pig was killed off of this movie Marvel
if you're listening just just put word
Pig's head back on our body and then put
her on my new Guardian Steve she's way
too badass looking to stay dead in my
opinion like come on I know she's
probably fried bacon on the surface of
the planet but you know you could just
wreck how that's just fine
and when the high evolutionary finally
faces off against Peter and Groot he
tells them of his plans to destroy
counter earth like he's done many times
before on other planets that he's
created very much like his comic book
counterpart did to counter Earth in
2015's uncanny Avengers number two by
Rick remander thus deepening the high
evolutionary similarities to the MCU
Celestial erishim the judge who has
threatened to bring the same type of
Destruction to Earth if the eternal's
memories show him things that he does
not like however when the high
evolutionary actually initiates the
destruction of counter Earth and Adam
Warlock flies to save Aisha a detail
about this moment that is very easy to
overlook is that Aisha did not choose to
leave her spaceship without her son Adam
though Aisha was literally one of the
douchiest people to ever exist in the
universe who repeatedly wanted to kill
Adam's adorable new pet fasaki blurp
throughout the movie we do get a deep
sense that she truly cared for both her
science experiment of a son and her
people like she wasn't a completely
heartless being she was just an [__]
but speaking of blurp this isn't the
first time the fasaki race has appeared
in the MCU as a hair of the spasaki can
be seen eating a bunch of orloni at a
bar in nowhere as the Guardians wait for
the collector and also fun fact about
nowhere in Guardians 3 the coordinates
to Nowhere are actually different from
the coordinates that we get in Guardians
1. this is of course because of the
mobile nature of the nowhere
installation thanks to the upgrades that
Peter and the Guardians have installed
on this giant Celestial head it can move
now but moving on after Peter pushes
recorder Thiel off of the orete labs and
Groot starts growing as tree Wings we
can actually hilariously see Peter and
Groot falling behind nebula mantis and
Drax as they all desperately tried to
enter orete Laboratories to save Peter
and Groot it really is quite the
hilarious blink and you'll miss it
visual gag but anyways once Peter and
Groot finally make it back onto their
ship to a rocket at death's door we can
see what appears to be the mcu's latest
depiction of the afterlife after first
being introduced to the concept in Black
Panther and then having the afterlife
concept further explained to us as
untethered Consciousness by in Moon
Knight because in the MCU it appears
that one's afterlife is highly dependent
on what that person personally believes
heaven to be wakandans believe in the
ancestral plain so all the wakandans go
there when they die the cree believing
the Supreme intelligence so all the cree
joined the collective Supreme
intelligence Consciousness when they die
Mark Spector believed in Egyptian
mythology due to his connection with
konchu so his afterlife was the field of
reeds Rocket's afterlife is a similar
situation in guard to the Galaxy vol 3
because heaven to the tortured prisoners
like rocket Lila floor and thieves very
much looks like a bunch of open cages
within a bright and infinite white Sky
because that is literally what all four
of them dreamed of all the time being
free in the Open Sky but what is super
special about this particular afterlife
case is that Rocket Raccoon had a choice
whether or not to keep on living because
after Lila says that raqqa can join her
floor and thieves in the afterlife
rocket breathes out a sigh of relief
because he can finally leave that
meaningless Universe behind and it is
that sigh of relief that directly leads
to his flatlining in the film and as
soon as Rocket flat lines Peter screams
at his side much like he did as a kid
while watching his mother Meredith die
and also like he did with yondu in
Guardians 2 when he died however it is
Lila herself who proves to be the
movie's greatest hero as her words to
Rocket about What Gives Life Meaning is
what sends his untethered Consciousness
falling down from the sky and back into
his body there are the hands that made
us
and then there are the hands that guide
the hands and that is when Lila became
one of my favorite MCU characters of all
time like what an incredibly selfless
and loving soul she was even in death
she missed rocket but still let him go
that takes a lot of strength but anyways
once mantis drags nebula finally make
their way inside of the orete they run
into the holding cells for all the high
evolutionaries star children cells that
appear to
us yellow liquid but the high
evolutionary appears to have injected
rocket with at the start of the film to
trigger Rocket's evolutionary growth
this liquid is probably what has helped
the star children evolve into the super
powerful beings that phyla appears to be
at the end of the movie I have a feeling
that this yellow liquid could
potentially be linked to the same yellow
evolutionary power found in The
Sovereign batteries or harvillary
batteries if you speak French which is
why rocket knew that the Sovereign
batteries could cause a chain reaction
throughout ego's nervous system in
Guardians 2. this is honestly why I
believe that the Guardians 3 Logo is
yellow this time around because
Guardians 3 is all about the concept of
evolution and it's the same reason why
the eternals logo is golden yellow as
well because much like that yellow MCU
energy caused rocket and phyla's
mutations in Guardians 3 yellow MCU
energy also helped the Deviant Crow
evolve after he shoved a swirly straw
inside of both ajac and Gilgamesh and
drank the yellow solar energy inside of
their bodies that they all got inside of
their bodies after sitting in front of
Earth's yellow star for so long long at
the beginning of the movie this could be
widely High evolutionary calls his
children his star children because of
the Star Energy inside of this yellow
juice not just because that they were
historic pupils but also because he used
the evolving radiation energy from
yellow Celestial Suns to make his
Evolution juice so much like the
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 Logo was
blue and red to denote the blue and red
energies of ego's Planet the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 Logo is golden
yellow to denote the concept of
evolution that's just a theory but
anyways when Star-Lord calls Craigslist
and steamy to bring nowhere to the orete
we can see craglin playing cards with
both Seth Green's Howard the Duck and
the broker from guardians 1 played by
Christopher Fairbank but what my
favorite part about nowhere rescuing all
the people and animals of the orete is
that nowhere is actually fulfilling the
purpose that the collector originally
had it for because we learn in a
Guardians 1 interview from Benicio del
Toro that the collectors collection on
nowhere was meant to be a Noah's Ark
type of Act of altruism because the
collector foresaw a coming catastroph be
in the universe that was going to
jeopardize all life so he started
collecting a bunch of living beings like
Noah did in the Bible in order to save
them that's a real creepy way of going
about things tanalear but hey everyone
needs a hobby then of course we get the
return of the interdimensional ableist
creatures from Guardians 2 who regularly
emerge from the cracks in reality around
Sovereign to feed on the yellow
Evolution and elex energy irradiating
from their planets one of my favorite
Parts about mantis of personality is her
immense kindness and empathy and I truly
love how mantis uses her kindness and
empathy to calm these Obelisk creatures
down because it perfectly exemplifies
what makes mantis so unique mantis is a
truly selfless being who cares so much
about defending others like when rocket
got hurt she attended to rock it even
though her own arm was broken she yells
at nebula for pushing Drax and she
spends the entire movie trying to heal
the hole in Peter's Heart by pushing
Peter to return to Earth if anyone is
the truest Guardian of the Galaxy it is
mantis in my opinion because mantis has
an extremely protective heart that is
always known known that all life has
meaning and that is what it truly means
to be a guardian of the galaxy and
that's why rocket chose to spare the
high evolutionaries life in the end and
why Groot told Adam that everyone
deserves a second chance because the
Guardians of the Galaxy would not exist
if they weren't all given a second
chance to be better people those
merciful words to Adam Warlock would
affect Adam Warlock greatly and then
cause him to start to become the
merciful Adam Warlock that we know from
the comics James Gunn having Peter and
Adam recreate Michelangelo's creation of
Adam while Adam saves Peter was such a
nice touch because of this but anyways
when rocket in the high evolutionary
finally face off the high evolutionary
Subs rocket against the wall with his
favorite anti-gravity powers that appear
to be rooted within his suit a suit that
behaves very similarly to Kang suit in
quantumania especially when Kane used
that suit to torture Cassie and Scott
but when the Guardians overpowered the
high evolutionary and take off his face
I don't think that this was just meant
to expose the true monster underneath
the high evolutionary but I also
believed that this was Marvel's way of
setting up the origin of the high
evolutionary's iconic purple mask that
he always wears in the comics for later
films because it doesn't look like his
skin mask is going to stick on his face
if you look at it in the deleted scene
but anyways as the Guardians escape the
orete with all the freed prisoners
mantis opens a cage for a tiny
Abomination that scares her this
monstrous creature is actually played
and voiced by director James Gunn if you
haven't seen the raw footage of this
moment I highly recommend that you do
because it is hilarious and James Gunn's
squat walking is just straight comedy
both the gun Brothers have amazing knees
and while Peter heads to deactivate the
shield so everyone can make it across to
nowhere he runs into a bug-eyed alien
with a gun this alien is named flectic
and he is played by Mr Steal Your Girl
himself Pete Davidson who of course
works with James Gunn in the past on The
Suicide Squad as the short-lived Black
Guard but anyways as the movie wraps up
Peter his journey throughout the movie
leads him to finally decide to stop
running from his fears and announce his
return to Earth which then inspires
mantis to face her own fear of going off
on her own for the first time ever since
ego in the Guardians which then forces
Drac to confront his own fear of losing
another daughter figure in his life
after Ronan killed his daughter before
Guardians 1. he wanted so badly to
protect mantis but he was forced to let
her go do her own thing just like Peter
had to face his fear of letting Gamora
go and nebula herself faced her fear of
vulnerability when she admits that she
needs racks with her to be a father
figure for nowhere after she spent the
entire movie being a crabby blueberry
who rejects help from almost everyone
like all the Guardians of the Galaxy
grow so much during this film I freaking
love it and of course the biggest
surprise of this movie is when Groot
says I love you guys to all of his
friends though a lot of people assume
that this was Groot finally learning to
say words Beyond I am Groot this is
actually not the case Groot is actually
saying I am Groot in this moment but
James Gunn purposely made us understand
Groot because we have spent so much time
with since 2014 so much like Gamora
began to understand Groot at the end of
the film The Audience has begun to
understand him as well but anyways when
Peter finally arrives back on Earth and
enters his grandfather's house in
Missouri we can see all of Meredith
Quill's music records and memories
against this wall but right next to a
picture of her and Peter we can see a
framed image that says everything grows
with love I believe this is a clear
reference to Ego The Living Planet and
how ego used Meredith's love to grow all
of his evil tumor plants as we can see
when Meredith and ego kiss at the
beginning of Guardians 2 it is love that
fueled ego's expansion and he deeded
Peter's heart to do that and finally
much like in Guardians 2 Guardians 3
ends with a shot of rock because much
like Lila says in the movie the story
has been Rockets all along but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
breakdown of Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 and I want to thank Paul once again
for his super generous and kind soul for
giving me the opportunity to do this
amazing breakdown on his amazing Channel
Guardians of the Galaxy has meant a lot
to me as a human being and it's taught
me a lot of lessons about the importance
of of human connection and love so
getting to do this breakdown has been an
absolute dream come true you rock Paul I
love you so much you're the best but
anyways if you want to hear more of my
weird voice please go subscribe to my
YouTube channel mass retainment or you
can follow me at mesertainment on
Twitter or X or whatever the hell
Twitter is called I don't know if you
guys want to see me post some weird [__]
because I'll be posting weird [__] all
day but of course most importantly do
not forget to subscribe to heavy
spoilers Paul is one of the absolute
best of the game so you don't want to
miss any of his breakdowns ever so hit
that subscribe button right now but
anyways thanks again so much for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I hope to see you guys again in
the future Tata and remember that all
life has meaning so be kind to one
another okay okay I'm watching you